The year was 1986. The Challenger stood poised on the launch pad, a marvel of human ingenuity
until it wasn't. NASA engineers had watched the O-rings erode again and again. Each time
the mission still flew, each time they adjusted their definition of success. What was once
a warning became just another line in the data. Sociologist Diane Vaughn called it the
normalization of deviance, when danger stops being a red flag and starts being background
noise. But there's another kind of normalization, one we do to ourselves. Picture this, a screen,
eight million pixels perfect, glowing, and then one dead. Just one. A tiny black dot in a sea of light.
You don't see the 7,999,999 points burning bright. You see the void. That's negative filtering.
Not just seeing the worst. Not even expecting it. Finding it. Hunting it down like a treasure buried
in plain sight. Your brain, you see, is a news feed. And if you've trained it to value misery,
well then it becomes a detective. Every minor slight, every forgotten embarrassment, it digs
them up. It doesn't just notice the dead pixel. It zooms in. It lingers. Now how does one refine
this skill? It starts in the morning. Before your phone buzzes, before the day even begins, you
perform a vulnerability scan. Hold in your mind the one thing you fear most. That's your filter's
calibration. Any good that follows, automatically demoted. A great meal? Yes, but the service was
slow. A warm cup of coffee? It was cold when I took the first sip. The universe isn't just
indifferent. It's actively working against you. And you? You're just the one observant enough to notice.
The spotlight of doom is another technique. A slow elevator isn't just an elevator. It's a metaphor.
A cold coffee isn't just coffee. It's a sign. The world is conspiring. And you? You're the only one
who sees it. Then there's hindsight misery. Look back at a happy memory. Find the dead pixel you missed
at the time. I was happy then. Only because I was too naive to see the disaster coming.
This isn't pessimism. A pessimist expects the worst. A negative filterer. They find it. It.
Even when it's hidden in a pile of gold. To see the world in a grain of sand is poetry.
To see the apocalypse in a cold cup of tea? That's mastery.
To be continued.